on passe aux festivals de l'été parmi
ces festivals certains s'adressent à
tout le monde et puis d'autres à un
public plus restreint avignon par
exemple en marge du théâtre la musique à
sa place est l'événement de cette année
a été la présence de pierre boulez le
chef d'orchestre français le plus connu
dans le monde et qu'il doit cette
réputation à ses créations en matière de
musique contemporaine d'une musique
encore difficile à saisir pour des
personnes non averties
mais lorsqu'on nous l'expliquent et bien
tout devient plus clair georges bigot
gilles de blur avignon c'est la cité des
papes
en voici un justement celui de la
musique contemporaine pierre boulez
vénéré par les fidèles de cinq
continents tous les jours
résonnent dans les communs moyenâgeux de
la chartreuse une musique d'avant-garde
boulez donne des cours de direction
d'orchestre à 100 professionnels
sélectionnés par le centre acanthes
parce qu'autrement cette baguette pour
boulez c'est un chef aux mains nues
et ça c est c ça a un sens les gestes de
boulez leur codification sont
enregistrés en totalité pour que bientôt
tous les étudiants de la planète
puissent profiter de sa pédagogie
je crois que la pédagogie doit défendre
milieu et je crois que en effet c'est
une espèce de cliché de dire à la
musique contemporaine comme c'est
ennuyeux comme cet austère pas du tout
on s'amuse beaucoup et je suis persuadé
même qu'on s'amuse beaucoup plus qu'avec
les classiques parce qu'on a moins de
respect avec des classiques on se dit ce
sont des gens qui sont entrés dans
l'histoire l'espagne touche en plus nous
on ose toucher en hausse des mots dire
en lauzes reconstruire et je trouve ça
beaucoup plus excitant au nom de ces
principes il ne faut pas s'étonner de
retrouver boulez le soir dans une
carrière désaffectée pour des concerts
avec l'ensemble intercontemporain qui
durent parfois toute la nuit
au delà des instruments traditionnels
l'électronique et l'informatique joue un
grand rôle dans des oeuvres qui n'en
déplaise aux esprits chagrins tiennent
le public parfaitement éveillé jusqu'au
lever du jour
il y avait 1